this is a production of Cornell
University thanks for having me
I just told Greg I need to apologize
that this is a veggie focused talk so my
appointment is all specialty crops I
plan on working in perennial perennial
fruits and small fruits as well but I
would say my thinking is a little more
mature when it comes to what I might do
in vegetable crops focus so rather than
kind of walk through and give you the
details of what I'm thinking about doing
what I've already started
maybe so what I've done in the past I
thought it might be a good approach to
share with you kind of how I think about
weed management problems in a more
general way and kind of dive into some
concepts and some theories that really
inform my thinking about about weed
management and so that's my plan and
we'll see I typically talk to extension
audience and so you don't really dive
into theory when you're talking to two
growers but I thought this might be a
nice opportunity to do some of that with
you guys
so you know you would think that you
know there's really only one goal when
it comes to management and that's we
want to kill as many weeds as possible
but there is some underlying theory and
how we design tactics to do that and
from an ecology standpoint we have
broader goals as far as what we want to
get out of our weed management programs
so we want to maintain low population
equilibrium densities and/or weed seed
banks and re-emerge populations we want
to avoid population Peaks so we want to
avoid bad years where we have you know a
huge yield loss and and huge weeds heat
rain events especially in herbal
communities and then also we want to use
tactics that prevent us from seeing
patience so specific wheeze becoming
adapted to our systems or specific weed
communities and so if that's the primary
goal there we go
we have this some we kind of have this
organizing framework called weed
community assembly and this has been
around for four years
a couple scientists rich Smith's up in
New Hampshire in Des Moines and it been
state of recently put a little a
different spin on weed community
assembly by connecting kind of the
ecological niche theory that underlines
this framework with kind of successful
ecologists ecology or disturbance a
disturbance framework and they the way
they conceptualize that is the way that
we communities come about they go
through a series of filters and so you
know in kind of classical ecology you
think about the niche theory is a series
of an abiotic filter that constrains
populations due to limiting environments
or disturbance or particular soil types
and biotic filters right so the
interactions between species
top-down/bottom-up but in arrabal system
so in a in a you know highly managed
system there's these additional filters
that we think about so the cropping
system filtering of a management filter
and they're hierarchical so the
higher-level filters constrain the
communities that pass through and then
also kind of constrain what options we
have for management at lower levels so
if we think about what the important
factors are and this is not an
exhaustive list of kind of what
encompasses these filters but when I
think about this hierarchical filter
here I think about the factors that
contribute to the weed species pool that
we have at the field level and so that's
a function of both tropical pressure so
species coming into the environment sea
bank legacies of annual weeds and then
perhaps shifting climate patterns you
see some of that already occurring as we
see some
new species meaning moving north and
latitude property or pressures a big one
now typically we think that it's really
the seed bank legacy that matters but
with this kind of emerging problem of
herbicide resistant weeds they're
getting spread over the region proc
you'll pressure is an important
important factor so the cropping system
so that's really what is the design of
your crop rotation
how many crops you have a notation
whether they're life cycles winter
annual summer annuals they're growing
season length the type of fertility
inputs that are particular to that
system and then really this is this is
kind of the important one so that when
you think about kind of the management
filter this is where we kill the weeds
right and so typically we're either
using herbicides broad-spectrum
herbicides selective herbicides or
tillage and cultivation or a combination
those those tools and these are high
disturbance intensity and frequency
events and so those create the very
conditions in which leads are adapted to
so weeds become adapted to disturbance
and they also are adapted to these
events which which we see slicing in
available resources and so you have this
filter below it and this is really the
internal internal dynamics this is the
this is where the ecology happens that
crop competition bottom-up top-down
level processes and so if we're thinking
about achieving those goals of
preventing adapted species in our system
what we really need to do is lower the
intensity of these disturbance events so
rely less on herbicides or tillage the
combination of both and rely more on
these filters above that
these processes so at the cropping
system level by diversifying crops and
the rotation the life cycles that we use
and then also increasing kind of the
biotic control control levels so once
you start tinkering with the cropping
system to only achieve
butwe management objective that's where
you run into issues because once you
start doing that you start tinkering
with that type of thing you are
influencing other components of the
system that we care about so that's why
when you think about taking that type of
diversified weed management approach
it's important to look at that in the
context of kind of the entire system and
so using kind of the agro ecology system
framework is really important for doing
that so you know I really ecology
principles are really based on just
minimizing and reducing external inputs
and relying more natural processes or
ecological processes to achieve both
pest management objectives and and soil
management or totality management
objectives so if we're changing tactics
to manage weeds in order to really
enhance biotic pest regulation we may be
producing trade-offs for other
components of the system that we care
about so increasing soil quality
increasing the efficiency of cycling
nutrients water conservation all those
factors and so the way I see it is you
know thinking about designing new ways
to manage weeds diversifying weed
management tactics the response to the
weeds is just as one response it's
really a multivariate response surface
that includes
dynamics related to soils and and other
pests and so these are these are the
goals that we think about when we're
thinking about adopting more
really ecologically based pests and
fertility management and this is the one
I think about a lot these days and
that's how do we design systems that are
resilient that have capacity to adapt to
disturbance and so we think about this a
lot in terms of climate change so
systems that that can adapt to changes
in the climate but also it could be
pests so that our resilience against new
pest problems so if that's the goal for
you know if the if the goal is to design
and evaluate we management practices
that accomplish those types of
objectives that's much different than
traditional weed science work and it's
because you know we can if we're
thinking about evaluating new herbicide
product we can pretty confidently come
up with what we think is the response
from a weak community standpoint this
particular herbicide controls these weed
species with similar functional traits
but if we're using diverse tactics or
creating a lot of trade-offs and I think
that's the real challenge for
incorporating that type of research into
an extension program and that how do you
how do you evaluate what those
trade-offs are how do you prioritize
what the trade-offs are and then how do
you communicate you know how do we think
about those trade-offs to a grower
audience and the other thing is that's
the processes that play out are really
just their context dependent because the
ecology of each system is a little bit
different and it's going to produce a
series of different trade-offs so
there's really a high level of context
dependency and so we don't get that
predictable response that we might see
with the herbicide if we're using the
burst tactics so I think that's that's
something I think about and I think it's
you know we're moving into kind of a new
era of extension weed science research
away from herbicide based programs and
so thinking about what a good extension
program looks like around diverse weed
management tactics is you know a
challenge okay so I mentioned this this
idea that we're thinking about building
our ecosystems are resilient they have
the adaptive capacity to disturbance
weather climate or related to pests and
I've been thinking about food system
resilience lately and so that really
just broadens our thinking related to
Agra the ecosystem resilience to kind of
socioeconomic processes and so the goal
of food system resilience is not just -
it's not about production but also about
access to foods and so it couples the
production process with distribution
channels and ties that to the consumer
and it's all about if we're if we're
going to have resilient food systems
people need to have access to the
diversity of products and it really
points towards redesigning our systems
around kind of locally or regionally
food economies and so you know if you
look at the factors or the processes
that are going to contribute to food
systems resilience it's not just
increasing diversity in our agro
ecosystems but also increasing diversity
of distribution networks increase
dietary diversity so they're thinking
about nutrient-dense healthy food
systems and so the reason why I've been
thinking about this is when I start off
talking about the hierarchy of
management filters that cropping system
filter really shapes what we have as far
as available management tools for weed
management and decisions at that level
are driven by economics they're driven
by do we have a market for that
particular crop
it may make sense from breaking pest
cycles or increasing soil quality but
it's it's a non-starter if it doesn't
make economic sense and so this this
kind of framework presents kind of a
normative case for redesigning a system
that diversity is really the core focus
so that that might seem fairly academic
and in some respects it may still be but
there's this really interesting book
that was published by Lauren Lange like
a couple of years ago I was called
resilient agriculture and she went
around the country and talked to she
talked to kind of leading-edge growers
across all types of production systems
so field crops vegetables food
production systems and asked how they
think about designing their system and
in the context of resiliency in the face
of changing climate and the way she
summarized almost all the growers when
they talk about resilience they talked
about resilience from you Kevin hydro
ecosystem standpoint so introducing crop
diversity they all prioritize practices
that build soil quality but they also
identify these economic components so
access to high value markets diverse
capital assets and so I've been thinking
about that so you know what are what are
the advantages and disadvantages and
challenges and opportunities in new york
if that is a long-term goal to build
more resilience in our food systems and
everybody knows new york is a
wonderfully diverse state when it comes
to the number of agricultural products
that we produce and so build into that
is this infrastructure this capital
infrastructure that supports all these
products we have the distribution
channels the value chain
and it's and it's pretty heterogeneous
spatially so up in around Geneva it's
pretty easy to go from a dairy farm to a
vineyard to a vegetable crop system
within just a mile or two and so that
heterogeneity perhaps presents some real
opportunities the other thing New York
has going for of course is it's it's got
some comparative advantage when you
think about location of the consumer so
being being in the Northeast close to
the eastern seaboard where we have a
very large percentage of our population
is another advantage and we're and we're
thinking about this so you know I'm a
big fan of the work that Christian
Peters did hear about a decade ago
thinking about these this concept of
food sheds in New York so there's
there's kind of in this kind of a some
thinking along those lines when we see
that popping up in different different
areas as far as thinking about local
aggregation Regional Food Network's in
New York so I just wanted to try to put
a finer you know provide some examples I
guess of what that might look like and I
you know if I haven't gotten everywhere
I wear what I would like to see in New
York yet but I've seen some interesting
operations and I just wanted to point
out a couple which I think demonstrate a
local adaptation to what I consider kind
of this resilience thinking and so both
of these examples are just down the road
from the Experiment Station in Geneva
maybe two or three miles away and so
here's one example is the hemdale farms
so Dale ham injure just outside of
Geneva and Hema jurors operate at 1200
Cal dairy and they're very invested
technology so they are moving more and
more of their production system to
robotic milking parlors so they have to
rely less on labor and then they also
specialize in specialty crops and really
cabbage so these this operation is
diversified it's a dairy and a
specializes in the cabbage I didn't know
of any dairy cabbage / cabbage
operations before I came to New York but
that level of diversification is really
important so right now there's
tremendous Fox in northeastern dairies
no prices are really low and small dairy
producers are really struggling right
now and so you think about how from both
in economics from an economic standpoint
diversification provides sort of
resilience so operations like the
hemming juries are probably going to be
able to ride out those periods of low
milk prices and also that level of
diversification also it makes sense
because they've worked out on really
closing nutrient cycling loops so doors
going back out onto fields ahead of
cover crops they're heavily invested in
soil quality practices integrating cover
crops reducing tillage so when we think
about what the previous slide what makes
systems resilience crop diversity
prioritizing soil quality diverse
capital assets I think I think the
hemdale farms is a good a good example
of that the other one is Rick Peterson
and the Peterson family farms just down
the road from Dale and he's very
diversified I'm not sure how many total
acres he has but he really specializes
in fresh market vegetable production
also grows field crops he's in close
proximity to a lot of dairies and
yes oh he can he can so field crops
locally he's also one of the largest hoc
growers in New York and he is starting
to grow more and more small grains major
grains in his rotation malting barley
hybrid rye those types of small grains
and his operation is about 50% certified
organic and the other 50% is non-gmo
crops so here he's diversified in crops
he grows and then also premium markets
so he has access to these really high
quality premium markets and he just like
Dale was very heavily invested in kind
of soil building practices so he thinks
about and integrates a cover crop
wherever you can in the rotation and
he's he doesn't do no-till but he's very
serious about reducing the intensity of
tillage system so he does this low till
kind of practice so to tie those things
together so the way I'm thinking about
designing a research and extension
program around developing diversified
weed management systems is that two
levels and it kind of corresponds to the
community assembly framework I shared
with you so at the lower level I'm gonna
be thinking about developing a diverse
set of we control tactics so combining
combining things like herbicides reduced
tillage cover crops with the goal of the
kind of overall goal of minimizing
external inputs where we can and then
also making sure that the combination of
those tactics still produce robust
weed control outcomes and then also
thinking about all those agro-ecosystem
trade-offs so understanding and
evaluating what those trade-offs might
be related to to new tactics and then
kind of a higher level and also want to
work in the development
or diversified cropping system practices
um that kind of build on the strengths
of of New York and the diversity of Ag
that we have as well as kind of you know
understanding and utilizing some of the
local adaptation that are already going
on like the Peterson farm or or or the
hemdale farm and then thinking thinking
about both you know ecological and
economic resilience by kind of using
agro ecology practices so I thought I
thought that I would run through an
example my previous work at Penn State
that kind of illustrates some of these
concepts let's kind of put a finer point
on that so I was at Penn State as a
postdoc for three and a half years prior
to coming here and principally my
responsibilities was as a project
coordinator for this long term cropping
systems experiment at Penn State I was
called the reduced till organic systems
experiment or rose and I came in this
project it was in his 30 years so it had
almost completed one three-year rotation
and then kind of helped the product
project transition into another funding
cycle where we kind of redesign the
system a little bit but the overarching
objective of this project was thinking
about how we can reduce the intensity or
frequency of tillage in organic annual
field crop rotation and so when we think
about these high disturbance weed
control tactics organic field crop
production is a pretty classic case so
we rely on intensive conversion tillage
followed by frequent cultivation events
to manage weeds and so those are the
conditions where we create adapter
we'd species are adapted we communities
so the project was really about how do
we diversify our tactics and move away
from that high intensity high high
frequency kind of weed management
practices so the way we did that was by
integrating and relying more on biotic
weed control measures and so the way we
did that was by growing really high
biomass cover crops and rolling them
down with the roller crimper and
planting cash crops into the rolled
killed cover crop and so this is just an
example we did this both in corn and in
soybean and so in front of corn we would
grow a batch and triticale mixture and
we would roll that down and no-till
plant field corn into it and then in
front of soybeans we would plant
Syrio rye allows your O'Ryan to get
really big roll that down and plant
soybeans in the end of that road mulch
and so here we're moving away from
intensive tillage conversion tillage and
we're moving away from in crop
cultivation or at least frequent in crop
cultivation and relying on this biotic
we control measure and then we also
looked at integrating tactics so in
combination with growing high residue
cover crops we used high residue
cultivation and so high res new
cultivation it's it doesn't convert the
soil so it leaves the residue on top
whereas traditional cultivation we kill
weeds by really mixing soil between the
rows so cultivation high res of the
cultivation is these broad flat sweets
that allow you to come in not invert the
soil but sever roots of weeds so we're
looking at that in combination with
different levels of residue and so the
way we were getting that is by delaying
turning
so if we terminated earlier we would be
working with lower levels of cover crop
biomass and so you can see this is a
determinate late we had lots of biomass
here we terminated about three weeks
earlier in this case lower levels of
biomass you can see we have already
established the cash crop so here's some
of the results from that study we just
published some of this work and indeed
science and so I'm just gonna be talking
about the soybeans just to kind of
narrow down down the story so we we
replicated these studies at three
different locations in the mid-atlantic
Delaware Maryland and Pennsylvania and
on the x-axis here you have this would
be the different termination dates so as
you move across the x-axis you'd
beginning into later termination dates
where we'd have greater levels of
biomass and then the two shades of gray
or with or without cultivation and so
you know we can run this through some
null hypothesis testing and we were able
to separate some means but I think just
looking at the effect size averaged
across years and locations is really
more informative because it points to
one of the challenges that I suggested
at the beginning of the talk and that we
see the response of these tests the
response to be really location specific
so we didn't see the same trend with
delaying terminations across three sites
we saw each each location really had its
unique response to those tactics so
that's that's one take-home and then I
think the other take-home is you know we
had a more consistent response at least
in directionality maybe not magnitude by
with the high residue cultivation in
comparison to delaying termination dates
and so that's pretty typical in which
and what we see we see a more robust
on sand using a herbicide or using a
cultivator and we would see in relying
on a kind of a biotic control measure
like cover crops so the other thing
we're interested in looking at is all
the trade-offs that were associated with
this so you know we were we were
delaying termination so that was a
three-week delay between the early
termination and the late termination and
we were generating different levels of
cover crop biomass and so you can
imagine that this create potentially
creates trade-offs related to other
pests and so one of the pests that we
had identify identifying as a trade-off
was there was this interaction with
termination date and the level of
termination efficacy with the roller
crimper and so when we terminated later
we we were terminating cereal ride
plants that eventually would produce
motor seed and we started dealing more
and more as we followed the rotation
with volunteer cover crops and so this
this panel here is just the rank
abundance of the leek community and the
seed banks and you can see between the
two different planting dates as we
decrease we delay termination all of a
sudden we get cereal rye popping up as
the primary species or the most abundant
species in the weed seed bank and that
produced effects in in the subsequent
cash crop so when we terminate late and
we sampled the winter wheat crop that
followed we saw higher levels of grain
contamination so if you're taking winter
wheat as a cash grain and you take to an
elevator you're going to get docked at
the elevator for sure having that level
of contamination
so that was one pest management
trade-off
another pest management trade-off was
related to the insect community so we
were tracking both predatory arthropods
and also early season insect pests and
so this is a structural equation model
that I was fitting to each site and and
each cash crop or we are trying to
identify what the yield limiting factors
were and what the interactions were
between these different variables in the
system and so at Pennsylvania when we
delayed the planting day we were
increasing our crab biomass but we were
also decreasing the number of predatory
arts prawns we had in the community and
and you know an organic system we're
relying on those predatory arthropods
for Biological control early season HFS
so there's this dynamic where we control
tactics are influencing pest management
of different pests one more trade off
and again so the other thing is is all
these things that I'm highlighting and
all the structural equation models were
really coming out to be very location
specific and so the dynamics that were
playing out or we're vastly different so
this example is from the Maryland
location and so this is one of the one
of the issues that we thought we would
see but we only saw at the Maryland
location is that when you delay
termination to really get more weed
suppression out of your cover crops you
have more issues with consistent stay in
establishment so it's just tougher to
get a no-till drill through higher
levels of biomass and you run into
issues of not being able to open and
close the seed furrow reduce stands and
so we actually saw that to be the case
at the Maryland location where as cover
crop biomass increased soybean
population with decreased
so again I'm just I'm providing all
these examples to really demonstrate
that while diversifying lead to fill
taxes is a really important goal if
we're going to develop and evaluate
those tactics we have to take really a
multi-variant
approach to that research and understand
what all the what is doing all the
components of the system the great when
its terminated or is it just bending it
down so it's it's a good question the
question was about the roller the roller
crimper how does actually kill the cover
cop so it kills in two ways
sheer weight and then it actually crimps
the stems in multiple locations
so that chevron pattern it's going to
crimp the vascular tissue and and if
it's if the Rye is standing up nice and
tall it's gonna crimp it in three or
four spots but it doesn't always kill it
yeah it's it's it's the termination
efficacy is related to the chronology of
ceará Ryan is the grain contamination
related to cranes that do survive yes
well yeah so if you terminate too late
yeah you're at a point if you're at an
thesis and if it doesn't you don't get a
good kill it goes you know the seed
matures yeah yeah
okay so then we transition into the next
three years and this is really I started
really managing the project at this
point and so we we kind of made some
adaptations based on what we learned in
the first three years and one of the one
of the changes we made was to try to get
around the trade-offs related to having
high levels of meet suppressive cover
crop loss but also making sure that we
can establish
cash crop and so we changed the way in
which we were roller crimping we went
away from the large roller crimper and
went to these integrated rollers that
run ahead of a no-till planter and had
these really heavier-duty row cleaners
and what that did was open up
consistently open up a wider referral
for us to get the seed pearl open and
closed and we were still using high
residue cultivation we were using and
adaptively we didn't have a no
cultivation cultivation treatment and
the treatments that we did changed as we
actually moved and we had this no-till
soybeans phase and in a different system
we managed the soybeans as a tilled
system using kind of conventional
techniques so moldboard plow ahead of
the cash crop this is an order you would
fly and called the bait before the crop
is up and then internal cultivate
several times and so we were comparing
what are the trade-offs between the
notes health system and full tillage
system in this case so here's some of
the data this is so much eliminating
word honor the three years have been
completed a master's student Rebecca
champagne just finished up and so this
is totally biomass compared to the
no-till system and the tilled system in
soybeans and so you can see that we got
pretty comparable levels of lead
suppression and I should note that we
have different standards in organic gel
crops anything below a thousand
kilograms per hectare is pretty good
that's probably not what you're shooting
for in a conventional system in
vegetables you definitely can't handle
that level of weed pressure but where we
did see some differences which was
interest and we started collecting data
are we data between the row and in the
row it's because we really had different
between the tilled system in the notes
Hill system we had different mechanisms
going on and we saw a difference we saw
a greater proportion of the total
biomass
was in the role in the Tilt system so I
the other thing I think is important is
again we're not decisions about what
type of approach we're going to adopt
may not be driven by weed control
performance in some respects they may be
driven by how variable these systems are
from year to year so we may prioritize a
system where we see less we control
failures over a five or a ten year
period and so one of the things that
we're trying to do is to partition the
variance out of the weed biomass to
understand what factors are contributing
to the variability that you see in total
weed biomass and so so this is the
tilled system between the row and in the
row the no-till system between the row
and integral and these are factors in a
multiple regression and these are this
is semi partial correlation so you can
think of it as the unique contribution
to the variance for each of these
factors and so I just want to point out
you know a couple of things that we saw
was the C Bank legacy seemed to be more
important in the tilled system and
highly disturbed system for both between
the row and in the road then so that's
that's an interesting pattern that
popped out there we saw a pretty
predictable response for in a row where
the main contributor the variability was
how well we did as far as crop
establishment which makes sense it crops
for the row they were more wheat
suppressive they canopy close sooner and
that's what drove variability in the
toad system but environmental conditions
so just the year-to-year variability is
what really drove we control performance
in the no-till system which is
interesting because I think what it
really is is the soil conditions and how
much disturbance we really did with
those broke layers that was really
driving the response and weed pressure
and so if we can identify where that
variability is then we can make
modifications to the system okay I
better finish up I'm gonna run through
this so that was the week and fell
tactics and now I'm gonna have to run
through the diversified cropping
practices quickly so even if we're you
know we have those events and it's often
the case in organic systems where we
have high weeds he during rain events we
have some weed control failures like
this example with giant Fox to illness
this year and the bees this is where the
rotation the cropping system comes in so
we're rotating to a winner annual cash
crop and we want to harvest a profitable
crop in this case but we one of the
principal factors that's going on here
is it potentially we wanted to drive
weed seed banks down so we want to
utilize that wary and you'd say
wintering any life cycle to drive down
weed seed banks so that we can go back
into summer annual or profitable cash
crop but we are also interested in well
can we do that and still reduce the
intensity of tillage in that phase of
the rotation so we had a system where we
actually no-till planted spelt into a
soybean stubble and we supplied the
fertility by using manure injection and
then frost seeded with a high with a
no-till drill our cover crop into the
winter grain so we had the cover crop
there when we took off the grain and
that was a de foliation event which is a
weed management tactic or a we control
tactic and then we either took a forged
cut or adaptively managed it and mowed
it to eliminate weed seed production and
we had systems where with different
levels of intensity as far as tillage
goes so we had a system where we had a
moldboard plow ahead of the spelt and
then also ahead of the cover crop we had
a system where we reduced the intensity
with the chisel plow all the way down to
this system I just described word for
two years
we had no-tillage in the system and this
is what the weeds he banks the play so
you can see each one of the systems in
both in two different starts we were
driving weed seed banks down a lot of
variability but in each case regardless
of the intensity of tillage means feed
banks were declining which indicates
that this may be a phase of the cropping
system where we can reduce intensity of
tillage frequency of tillage and still
manage weed seed banks I'm going to skip
this one just so I can wrap up so just
to bring it back to kind of the my plan
I guess and so just to summarize and I
think this is a this is a rough plan
this is an evolving plan but I'm really
thinking about if we think about kind of
the original community community
assembly the goal is to reduce the
intensity those high intensity control
events so that's that would be one of
the goals of my research and so that's a
multi-pronged approach includes
herbicide stewardship so we're using
right herbicide at the right time at the
right rate there's opportunities for
precision lead control using precision
and edge technology that's coming along
very interested in reduced tillage
practices
I knew this program is that I want a
great work in this area which I hope I
can I can work with her on and then
developing these biotic based we control
tactics so thinking about how we can
effectively integrate cover crops into
the rotation what that means for grading
them with other weed control tactics
like herbicides or cultivation and then
finally evaluating and developing
different kind of cropping system level
diversification strategies and so my
first I went big for my first grant
proposal and just just submitted an REI
I submit an REI with Marc Farrell's
and Gary Bergstrom and Sarah Etheridge
and Miguel Gomez and so that's going to
look at thinking about ecological
resilience and economic resilience by
utilizing these high-value winter annual
grains that work has been working on I
was reading programs so the heritage
grains the ancient grains he's been
working on mantle barley all these
winter grains have premium markets they
have secondary premium secondary markets
feed feed grade quality rings and so the
economics potentially makes sense and
then we want to look at where the
cultural practices that kind of increase
our ecological resilience and vegetable
crop rotations so I about talk through
the entire time but I'll stop there and
take questions in the species
composition or function type composition
in your weed communities in relation to
any of your control strategies yeah yeah
we so the question was about shifting
either community composition or the
functional traits so that last slide you
know this we have a really good meaty
bank data for these last three years and
so I'm just starting to dive into the
community level analysis and the first
shot
this particular analysis indicated that
we we were we weren't seeing dramatic
shifts in the week between in that phase
of the rotation along a disturbance that
tillage gradient and I think it could be
for two reasons one is there's a pretty
well-established eBay legacy at this
point and the other reason is we might
not have sampled at the intensity we
needed to to to identify a shift in
communities I actually think that when I
cut the week me a question is
interesting from an ecological
standpoint if we see a shift in the
community but Biron what happens is you
get a lot of innocuous needs in a week
that may be jumping out and indicate you
know showing a shift personally and
speed well that's not a species that's
going to be yield lemonade so I think I
what I was doing was pulling out weed
species that we knew we know to be
abundance and potentially yield limiting
in the corn crop in the next phase of
the rotation and looking at see Bank
chef's transition rates so I think it's
a better approach would be to look at
functional traits so mid season summary
annual weed species what are they what
are they doing rather than looking for a
shift so we're not applying but anyone
who has further questions or would like
to dialogue with Professor Wallace that
you'll be around for a few minutes and
speak to it thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu